vegan food is like got really good but
whenever they talk about vegan food they
talk about it being fresh and colorful
and you know all of that they don't
really talk about being luxurious and
decadent and and so one of the things i
said i've never had a great vegan
lasagna
and so
the jamie basically
sorted out this uh this amazing
vegan lasagna and i was sort of cookie
we were cooking together and then my mum
was there my mum i just want to take
this opportunity i love john i want to
apologize for that she got so battered
it was
it was crazy man she got absolutely
hammered quite a lot and then
there's loads of stuff that she was
saying i think is pretty cancelable and
then you left to let me get on with it
and then she's going you're not as good
as jamie
why can't you do this i think it's jamie
oliver jeremy how do you expect me to be
as good as him she was like going nuts
anyway
we did the lasagna
and it tasted unbelievable like it was
incredible man it was so good
but i'm slightly embarrassed by how i
just went thank you so much and i hugged
him
like i've been reunited with my
estranged dad or something it was so
it was so humiliating and then
afterwards i was as i was going home i
was thinking that's going to be bad when
it goes out i mean that that's that's
going to look really i'm so i was really
it was a beautiful moment because the
thing is as well like out of 50 shows i
genuinely did want him to love it and
when you're trying to earn flavor when
you haven't got any meat or dairy like
you gotta work hard so i i tested that
for like a month
um to get it that good and so i was
praying that it would have that reaction
and the production said please pretend
you like it
[Laughter]
[Music]